osservate queste immagini
la prima è un osso di femore umano in
particolare vediamo la testa del femore
con la tipica organizzazione a nido
d'ape in cui le traveggole che lo
costituiscono non sono disposte
casualmente come potrebbe sembrare
ma in realtà sono disposte lungo le
linee di trazione di forza dell'osso per
poi scaricare queste forze proprio sulla
parte mediana perché è più resistente
le altre due immagini invece
appartengono al mondo dei vegetali in
particolare abbiamo la pianta del loto
che a questa particolarità di avere le
foglie sempre pulite
nonostante l'habitat di questa pianta
siano acque stagnanti e fangose e questo
perché la superficie delle foglie è
costituita da delle strutture
gerarchiche fino ad arrivare a delle
dimensioni sub micrometriche che
conferiscono delle proprietà super
heathrow idrofobiche alla superficie
quindi l'acqua arriva e rotola sulla
foglia portando via lo sporco
la terza pianta invece è un'arte più la
pa che ha questa caratteristica di avere
queste strutture uncinate sia sui fiori
che sui frutti che rimangono attaccate
quelli degli animali ea una strategia
per
trasportare i semi ma che cosa hanno in
comune queste tre immagini tutte e tre
sono state fonte di ispirazione per
delle idee innovative in campi diversi
quali ad esempio la tour eiffel gustave
eiffel prese proprio ispirazione dall
organizzazione delle trave cole per
progettare la torre che era all'epoca la
più alta e per evitare che la questa
struttura collassasse sotto il proprio
peso oppure pitture che danno
conferiscono questo effetto loto a delle
superfici che diventano autopulenti o
addirittura una delle più note soluzioni
di respirata il veltro che prende
proprio ispirazione fu ideato da giorgio
de maistre al da come in questi uncini
rimanevano attaccati a quelli del suo
cane quindi la bio ispirazione molte
sono le idee che ci circondano e sono
via ispirata e quindi al mondo della
natura e la bio ispirazione anche il
nostro campo quindi noi studiamo la
natura di esseri viventi per tradurre
dei loro principi in nuove macchine i
nuovi robot per applicazioni varie poi
ne vedremo alcune ma l'obiettivo è anche
quello di utilizzare queste piattaforme
robotiche per capire meglio come
funziona l'elemento biologico dal quale
partiamo quindi il nostro obiettivo è
fare scienza e tecnologia
ma perché la biologia e robotica quando
effettivamente la natura può
rappresentare un valore aggiunto in
robotica
perché se noi vediamo un tipico diciamo
scenario industriale in questo caso i
robot si muovono in contesti in ambienti
che vengono definiti strutturati quindi
si muovono secondo delle procedure che
sono definite il pro botte
preprogrammato l'interazione con
l'operatore umano è limitata per motivi
di sicurezza ma se noi prendiamo questi
robot e li portiamo fuori dalle
fabbriche i robot si trovano ad operare
in un mondo reale
mondo dove vivono gli esseri viventi un
mondo che non è strutturato un mondo che
è imprevedibile e quindi in questo caso
la biologia può veramente offrire delle
nuove idee e quindi la natura con i suoi
cinque regni ci offre tantissime idee
andiamo dai batteri ai protisti con le
amebe i funghi gli animali le piante e
vi sono dei colleghi a livello
internazionale che già stanno studiando
i batteri in particolare le loro
capacità di locomozione basate su cda
flagelli perché funzionano meglio alla
microscala rispetto ad esempio alle
pinne dei pesci studiano questi
movimenti per progettare dei robot che
nel futuro si muoveranno all'interno del
nostro corpo per applicazioni mediche ma
la maggior parte dei robot sono ispirati
al mondo degli animali quindi esistono
tantissimi già robot e sviluppati che
prendono per esempio ispirazione da vari
animali e sono in grado di nuotare
volare arrampicarsi esaltare per
applicazioni molteplici che vanno dall
esplorazione ad esempio all'assistenza
degli uomini e addirittura al
salvataggio ma fino ad oggi nessuno
aveva pensato alle piante come nuova
fonte di ispirazione e robotica quindi
nessuno fino ad ora perché il nostro
gruppo è il primo a livello mondiale che
prende ispirazione dal mondo delle
piante in particolare dalle loro radici
per realizzare un robot che si muove
nello stesso ambiente per l'esplorazione
quindi per il monitoraggio dell'ambiente
ma perché le piante perché nel nostro
immaginario quindi nell'immaginario
collettivo le piante sono spesso
considerati degli organismi passivi che
non sono in grado di muoversi non sono
in grado di interagire
o di comunicare ma nella realtà
le piante sono in grado di muoversi di
interagire di comunicare lo fanno in
maniera molto efficiente lo fanno in
maniera diversa da noi quindi si muovono
crescendo per tutta la vita e quindi si
adattano plasticamente all'ambiente che
cambia sono in grado di muoversi
rispondendo a degli stimoli chimici o
fisici sono in grado di muoversi
rispondendo a degli stimoli tattili e
poi comunicano comunicano con altre
piante con un'unica know con animali ad
esempio anche per motivi di difesa
comunicano addirittura con le iv e dei
funghi creando delle simbiosi con queste
strutture e creando delle vere e proprie
reti sotto il suolo per comunicare e
addirittura si estendono per chilometri
quindi il nostro modello sono proprio le
piante in particolare sono le radici
delle piante noi andiamo a studiare come
le radici si muovono nel suolo in un
ambiente estremamente complesso dove le
pressioni e gli attriti sono veramente
elevate giovane crimi centimetri e loro
lo fanno è possibile perché crescono
dalla punta aggiungendo cellule poi
spingendo per osmosi
inoltre sempre a livello dell'apice
radicale hanno molte capacità sensoriali
quindi rispondono per esempio al tatto
le radici toccano continuamente
l'ambiente per capire dove penetrare nel
suolo no la strada migliore ma hanno
anche risposte alla gravità all'acqua
alla luce alle sostanze chimiche no
quindi capire come fanno estrarre
principi dal modello biologico e poi
tradurlo ovviamente semplificando in
tecnologia e quindi questo è uno dei
robot che abbiamo sviluppato un modello
di radice robotica che prende
ispirazione proprio dal la capacità
dell'apice radicale di rilasciare
continuamente cellule morte per creare
una specie di interfaccia tra la radice
naturale e il suolo e quindi ridurre
attrito ma la vera novità sta nella
crescita come dicevo le radici crescono
e quindi anche il nostro robot
analogamente cresce forma la propria
struttura si è auto crea come una stampa
una stampante 3d deposita gli strati uno
dopo l'altro dove il primo strato è
sempre quello a contatto con l'apice
radicale quindi l'unica parte che viene
spinta nel suolo è la punta
questo è uno dei robot che abbiamo
sviluppato anche le foglie sono ispirate
alle piante in particolare il materiale
delle piante perché molti movimenti
nelle piante sono passivi e sono dovute
proprio all'organizzazione dei materiali
che interagiscono con le variazioni di
umidità dell'ambiente e quindi in questo
modo abbiamo creato delle foglie che si
muovono rispondendo all'umidità alla
temperatura poi radici con dei sensori
integrati che abbiamo sviluppato ma
anche il relativo comportamento per cui
abbiamo per esempio dei comportamenti
negativi come la risposta al tatto la
radice cerca di evitare gli ostacoli
oppure positive come nel caso della
gravità o dell'umidità e poi la radice
che cresce per aggiunta di materiale ma
che cosa possiamo fare con un planetoide
quali sono le applicazioni di questo
robot
diciamo che in linea di principio
molteplici perché il plant o ed è un
dimostratore di tecnologia però una
delle idee principe che abbiamo avuto è
quello di utilizzarlo per il
monitoraggio del suolo quindi per
applicazioni ambientali perché dipende
dai sensori che noi andiamo a integrare
nella punta e possiamo cercare l'acqua
in maniera autonoma oppure i nutrienti
metalli pesanti quindi anche inquinanti
oppure pensare un applicazione nello
spazio perché quello che ci interessa
non è soltanto la capacità di
esplorazione delle radici ma anche le
capacità di ancoraggio la prima cosa che
fa l'apparato radicale stabilizza la
pianta per poi crescere e infine in
diciamo applicazione a lungo termine ci
immaginiamo delle applicazioni mediche
in cui li endoscopi del futuro
potrebbero essere flessibili e proprio
perché imitano il movimento della pianta
in realtà non creano danno ai tessuti in
questi casi biologici
quindi vorrei concludere diciamo con
alcune osservazioni sulle piante le
piante hanno colonizzato la terra
milioni di anni prima di noi sono
perfettamente adattate al loro habitat e
mostrano delle funzioni che sono molto
simili alle nostre
ma basate su the fondamenti biologici e
diversi quindi lo studio della pianta
come del resto di altri organismi
viventi ci aiuta ovviamente a fare
innovazione a creare nuove macchine
nuovi robot ma molto importante ci aiuta
anche a capire meglio come funzionano
gli esseri viventi che coabitano con noi
questo pianeta e quindi a rispettarli di
più grazie